عقارب الساعه تقترب من ساعه الصفر التاسع
مما يذكر النصر على النازيه هنا في
المناطق الانفصاليه وفي روسيا بشكل عام
ترقب كبير وحذر شديد من الهجمات
الاوكرانيه المضاده لكن المشهد على الارض
يختلف تماما خالد فالقوات الروسيه هي التي
تنفذ هجمات قيل بانها الاولى من نوعها غير
مسبوقه على جميع المدن الاوكرانيه حيث
من المدن استهدفت فيها القوات الروسيه كما
تقول مواقع عسكريه ومخازن للذخيره كما ان
المشهد هنا على الارض متطور جدا يعني خلال
الاربعه وعشرين ساعه كانت ليله صاخبه ان
كان في باخمت او مارنكا في باخ متخاص خاصه
تقدمت القوات الروسيه
وثمانين مترا في المنطقه والحديث عن حوالي
كيلومترين لاكمال السيطره على باقمت بعد
ان اعلن بريغوجين ان الجيش الروسي
سيدعمه وهو ينتظر الذخيره التي طلبها
لاكمال السيطره على باقمه وهذا يعني الغاء
لعمليه الانسحاب المقرره في العاشر من هذا
الشهر ايضا كان هناك
عمليات هجوميه كبيره في مدينه ابديفكا كان
الحديث عن قنابل ذكيه سلاح الجو لم يتوقف
طيله ليله امس وايضا صباح اليوم الحديث عن
محاولات اختراق وتوسيع الطوق ولكن
بعمليات هجوميه وعمليات اقتحام اكبر بكثير
من السابقه مارينكا ايضا شهدت يعني عدد من
الهجمات لكنها كانت متواتره مثل الايام
السابقه الا ان المدينه منخفض فيها حتى
الان سقوط القذائف والصواريخ قتيل واحد
وعده الاصابات في احياء مدينه المحور
الاهم اذا سمح الوقت وبعجاله كرسون
وزبروجي التي تشهد معارك عنيفه جدا حيث
اجلى لجميع السكان او معظمهم من المناطق
القريبه من المحطه النوويه مع ارتفاع في
منسوب المياه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
لاغراق المحطه واعاده السيطره عليها وفي
خرسون محاولات لعبور النهر للوصول الى
مراكز الجيش الروسي من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني الهجمات المضاده متوقع ان تكون
في الجنوب الاوكراني وليس في دمباس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات